la educación está en peligro en nigeria
las tengo miedo de volver a la escuela
por lo que pasó pero volveré si el
gobierno aborda la inseguridad de
pupitres vacíos y ropa abandonada son
los restos del internado femenino de
ciencias en hunger en el noroeste del
país luego de que hombres armados
secuestraran a 317 alumnas durante la
noche del jueves sans y ya es una de las
jóvenes que logró escapar de sus
captores como en las sequías
vinieron tres grupos el del medio
irrumpió en nuestro albergue luego
algunas empezamos a correr hacia el baño
y otras nos escondimos debajo de la cama
ellos nos pedían a todos que saliéramos
nos insultaban diciendo que éramos
nosotros los que comíamos la comida del
gobierno nos pidieron que saliéramos de
nuestros escondites disparando al aire
todos teníamos miedo y gritábamos
desde el tercer ataque a un colegio en
nigeria en menos de tres meses sucesos
que han revivido los traumáticos
recuerdos de las niñas de chivo
secuestradas por los yihadistas de boko
haram en 2014 los padres de las jóvenes
esperan resignados noticias de la misión
de rescate que intenta localizar a las
niñas y critican al gobierno por su
ineficiencia
si hacemos un llamamiento al gobierno
debe hacer lo mejor para que esas niñas
vuelvan y para que garantice la
seguridad a los ciudadanos nigerianos
porque está dando vueltas
y si es grau el gobierno tiene que hacer
algo más fuerte que antes
los asesinatos la violencia sexual y los
secuestros masivos para pedir rescates
han aumentado drásticamente en el norte
de nigeria unos ataques que atentan
contra el derecho a la educación de los
estudiantes nigerianos en una región
donde el 80% de la población vive en la
extrema pobreza